On paper, they should be great allies.
Something like the Batman and Robin or Frodo
and Sam of international politics.
Let me explain.
Japan and South Korea are relatively free
countries in a geopolitical environment that
has some very unusual conditions.
They share partners, face the same threats
and have strong economic ties.
Sounds like a pretty good match but here’s
more...
We’re talking about two countries that have
the same strategic ally: The United States,
which currently has a total of almost 80,000
soldiers deployed in Japan and Korea.
Virtually a full army.
In addition, both countries face the same
challenges and the same threats, mainly an
aging population, as well as growing economic,
political and military weight from both North
Korea and China.
And that's not all.
With bilateral trade that exceeds $80 billion
per year and a transit of more than 10 million
tourists, Japan and South Korea’s economies
are very interrelated.
So as you can see, they tick all the boxes
to be very good friends.
What’s more, together, South Korea and Japan
form a much stronger block than you could
imagine.
We’re talking about a block that has 177
million inhabitants;
a combined economy of more than 6.5 billion
dollars;
an industrial production that doubles that
of Germany and is 5 times that of France
And it has the third largest military budget
on the entire planet, standing just behind
the United States and China.
Together, they spend more than $ 90 billion
each year on defense.
In other words, if you had to work as consultants
for these two governments, you’d surely
advise them to strengthen their ties and work
side by side, right?
Well, folks, just a second because theory
is one thing but the reality is something
altogether different.
The truth is that Japan and South Korea really
don’t get along.
And that explains news stories like this:
(Naval incident causes a surge in tension
between South Korea and Japan.
Military Zone)
(Forget North Korea: Is the Next Showdown
in Asia Japan vs. South Korea?
The National Interest)
And now more than ever, this topic is a hot
one.
Need proof?
Well check it out, according to a study conducted
in July of 2019, no less than 74% of Japanese
people reported a distrust of South Koreans.
And apparently the feeling is mutual, 75%
of South Koreans distrust Japanese.
But folks, of course, this doesn't end there.
At the beginning of July 2019, the Japanese
government unleashed a sort of trade war against
South Korea.
More specifically, it restricted the exports
of three key products to South Korean industry:
Fluorinated polyamide, hydrogen fluoride and
photoprotectors.
Ok, you may have never heard of them but we’re
talking about three chemicals that are essential
for manufacturing things such as semiconductors
or smartphone screens.
And these are two components for which South
Korea is one of the largest manufacturers
and exporters on the planet.
In fact, we could say that semiconductors
are something like South Korea’s oil.
("South Korea is the world leader when it
comes to chip-making, and Japan is the world
leader in the manufacturing of the key materials
for chip-making," Ahn Ki-hyun, vice-president
of the Korea Semiconductor Industry Association.)
And no, it doesn't end there either.
At the beginning of August, Japan announced
new restrictions... which may not be the last.
But, folks, before we continue, I think we
need to ask ourselves some questions...
What exactly is going on?
Why did Japan unleash such a conflict with
one of its biggest trading partners?
What consequences could it have?
Listen up.
(THE RECONCILIATION THAT NEVER ARRIVES)
To understand the entire story, we need to
go back to the beginning of the 20th century.
From 1910 until the end of World War II in
1945, Korea was a Japanese colony.
These weren’t exactly happy years for the
Koreans.
Folks, the Japanese Empire ruled Korea with
an iron fist; there was a very, very tough
repression; huge amounts of crimes were committed
and many lands were de facto expropriated.
To give you an idea, while the South Korean
people went hungry, a lot of the agricultural
production was sent to Japan.
And there’s more.
During the Japanese occupation hundreds of
thousands of South Koreans were forcibly recruited
to work in brutal semi-slavery conditions
in Japanese industry and mines.
Stanford University estimates that this included
more than 700,000 South Koreans.
But... if you think this is horrible, hold
on, because things get even worse.
During World War II, tens and tens of thousands
of South Korean women were forced to practice
the oldest trade in the world to “satisfy”
Japanese soldiers.
It’s estimated that between 50,000 and 200,000
women were victims of this atrocity.
Folks, all this explains why 7, seven decades
later, Japan and South Korea continue to fight
over what the occupation meant.
(“A local government near Seoul is calling
for all Japanese-made school products to be
affixed with a sticker saying they were made
by ‘war criminals”.
South China Morning Post.)
Of course, since South Korea regained its
independence in 1945, there have been several
attempts to reconcile and turn the page.
The two most important ones happened in 1965
and in 2015.
And both had the same result.
You see, in 1965, when South Korea was a dictatorship
led by Park Chung-hee, both countries agreed
to end all disputes.
Japan assumed its responsibility and promised
to pay the South Korean government the equivalent
of 2.4 billion dollars as compensation and
another 1.6 billion in low interest loans.
Everything sorted then?
Well, no.
In 2012, South Korea’s Supreme Court recognized
the victim’s right to obtain individual
compensation.
And not from the Japanese government, but
from the Japanese companies that were involved
in the forced labor cases.
The fact is that, in 2018, the South Korean
Supreme Court’s ruling led companies such
as Nippon Steel, Mitsubishi Heavy Industries
and the Nachi-Fujikoshi Corporation to pay
between 70,000 and 90,000 dollars to each
of the two dozen victims who’d made a claim
before the courts...
And that’s where it all lies.
The ruling ordered compensation for the victims
or their living relatives.
Because of course, some had already passed
away.
And here lies the heart of the matter:
Can you imagine if the same happened with
all the other forced workers, living or dead,
if their families could make a claim today?
We’d be talking about compensation amounting
to billions of dollars which, of course, Japan
has no intention of paying,
Because, among other things, from their point
of view, this whole issue had already been
resolved by the 1965 agreement.
On the other hand, in 2015 both governments
agreed that Japan would create a fund of about
$9 million to compensate the women who were
enslaved during World War II.
Well...
You know what?
This agreement was also worthless.
Why?
Listen up.
(THE BIGGER FIRE STRATEGY)
The South Korean economy isn’t going so
well right now.
We’ve already talked about it here on VISUALPOLITIK,
I’ll leave a video link in the description.
Folks, since Moon Jae-In came to power, things
have been unraveling almost as fast as snapchat
photos disappear.
And, of course, the president's own popularity
has followed closely behind the economy.
According to polls, President Moon Jae-In’s
approval dropped from 83% in May 2018 to 45%
a year later.
And not only that, this is also a time when
economic affairs are gaining more and more
power.
The South Korean leader's economic management
plummeted down to 30%.
And…
Well, here’s a question: what do you do
if you have a huge fire but you want people
to look the other way?
You make an even bigger fire.
I didn’t make that up, it’s one of the
oldest tricks in politics.
Well that's exactly what Moon Jae-In seems
to be doing: pouring gasoline on to the other
fire.
Which doesn’t seem to have been too hard,
because, folks, since he reached power in
2017, Moon Jae-In has always been focused
on Japan.
In fact, one of his first actions was to announce
the unilateral and retroactive suspension
of the 2015 agreement.
And since then, tensions between the two countries
have only grown.
Want some examples?
Well, check this out, in the last year we’ve
witnessed increasingly controversial and almost
provocative political statements from the
South Korean government against Japan.
South Korean intelligence has stopped sharing
the information it has with Japan;
In December 2018, according to Japanese sources,
a South Korean frigate set its shooting radar
on a Japanese plane.
Shortly after, Seoul prevented Japanese defense
force ships from using its ports.
And even as recently as the beginning of 2019,
we’ve seen a boycott on the purchase of
Japanese products which was instigated by
the South Korean government itself.
Come on, if what he’s looking for is a fight,
the South Korean president couldn’t be doing
a better job.
(“The bilateral relationship right now is
about as bad as it has ever been, and it is
continuing to deteriorate”.
Ahn Yin-hay, professor of international relations
at Korea University)
The point folks, is that it seems like Moon
Jae-In didn’t think that Japan would respond
with such strength.
Or maybe he did?
(TRUMP OPENS THE DOOR, JAPAN WALKS RIGHT IN)
Donald Trump was a pioneer of this tactic:
using commerce as a launching weapon in international
political negotiations.
Now Japan has gone one step further: they
are using the trade war to punish an ally.
Japan has had enough.
And Shinzo Abe can’t deal with it anymore.
He thinks that the South Korean issue and
all their pending quarrels have gone too far:
The 1965 agreement, the apologies of 1990,
1991, the 2015 agreement.
Tokyo isn’t willing to make any more concessions.
Of course, to be fair, the fact that the Prime
Minister himself is a convinced revisionist
doesn't really help.
We also talked about that recently in another
video.
The fact is that, at the beginning of July,
the Japanese government decided to punish
Korea with the restrictions on the three components
we mentioned before:
Fluorinated polyamide, hydrogen fluoride and
photoprotectors.
We’re talking about a measure that, if not
reversed soon, could cause great problems
for some South Korean giants like Samsung
or SK Hynix, two of the world's largest semiconductor
manufacturers.
And that's not all.
At the beginning of August, the Japanese government
communicated its decision to remove South
Korea from its white list of 27 countries
that have preferential commercial status.
Basically the countries on this list can buy
most Japanese technology and products freely
and without restrictions.
This means that to buy practically any product,
except food and wood, South Korean companies
will have to comply with the Japanese government’s
approval process, which not only involves
more bureaucracy and import costs, it also
means that the Japanese government now has
the right end of the stick.
That is, they can veto any sale to South Korea
at will.
And this, folks, is something that, given
the deep commercial relations between the
two countries, could be a hard blow for Korea….
And not only for Korea, but also for Japan,
which has a trade surplus with its neighbor
of more than 20 billion dollars.
The official excuse?
That South Korea can’t guarantee that all
these product and technology exports with
possible military use won’t reach North
Korea.
As an example, hydrogen fluoride isn’t only
used in semiconductor production, it can also
be used for uranium enrichment or to manufacture
sarin gas.
Although this sounds like quite an excuse.
Of course, the real reason is the endless
controversy that surrounds this happy colonial
past.
(The Japanese accusations are very serious,
but they have not provided evidence of any
collusion between South Korea and North Korea
so far,” Céline Pajon, a Japan expert at
the French Institute for International Relations.)
Of course, at this point, folks, the question
we have to ask is: does it make sense to resort
to commercial warfare as a foreign policy
weapon?
Well, the truth is that experience and evidence
say no.
You see, now the South Korean government isn’t
only responding with its own sanctions, they’re
also putting a lot of money on the table to
reduce their dependence on Japanese companies.
In a way, it’s similar to what happened
with China in 2011.
Back then, the Chinese government restricted
the sale of rare lands to Japan.
And what do you think the Japanese did?
They invested in their own mines.
In the end, China's market share decreased
and Japanese taxpayers had to pay for it.
That is, the outcome was bad for everyone.
So yes.
This time, Shinzo Abe’s shot may backfire
again.
Anyway, folks, what is most likely is that
Japan and Korea will sooner or later return
to the starting point and continue this endless
spiral of grievances.
But, you know what?
It’d be good for everyone to settle this
matter once and for all.
It has been 70 years.
Enough, right?
(THE BLOC)
Folks, a close alliance between South Korea
and Japan would frankly be a very good thing.
They would form an economic and political
block with tons, tons of influence.
For example, they’d have a free trade agreement
with China, which Japan and South Korea are
negotiating jointly.
Progress has slowed down now with Moon Jae-In
but once it is settled it will create an even
wider arena for trade.
That would be good for everyone.
On a political level, they’d become a beacon
in an area of ​​the world that is full
of dictatorships.
And at a military level, they’d be able
to offset China’s weight.
Even with the army that the United States
has deployed in these countries.
But of course, to achieve all this, it’s
absolutely essential that both governments
reach an agreement to once and for all leave
the past behind and focus on the future.
So I really hope you enjoyed this video, please
hit like if you did, and don’t forget to
subscribe for brand new videos.
Don’t forget to check out our friends at
the Reconsider Media Podcast - they provided
the vocals in this episode that were not mine.
Also, this channel is possible because of
Patreon, and our patrons on that platform.
Please consider joining them and supporting
our mission of providing independent political
coverage.
And as always, I’ll see you in the next
video.
And as always, thanks for watching!